[Música]
hablamos por supuesto de economía en
directo americana france24 daniela
blandón bienvenida vamos a hablar de la
energía no como tema principal del día
de hoy porque se acerca el invierno y en
europa no descartan una crisis
energética
occidente también quiere imponer un
precio límite al precio de los
hidrocarburos rusos al así de raúl pues
ya hay acuerdo entre los ministros de
finanzas del grupo de los siete
conformado por canadá francia alemania
italia japón reino unido y eeuu esto
para avanzar en la fijación de un tope
al precio que se le paga a rusia por su
petróleo y gas
bruselas por ejemplo acusa al presidente
ruso vladimir putin de manipular el
mercado energético con sus constantes
cortes de suministro
hemos acordado un almacenamiento común y
el nivel de almacenamiento en europa
ahora es del 80% esto se logró más
rápido de lo esperado hemos trabajado
intensamente para salir de nuestra
dependencia del gas ruso recurriendo a
otros proveedores a estas alturas
noruega entrega más gas a europa que
rusia eeuu entrega grandes cantidades de
gas natural licuado a europa pero todo
esto no es suficiente se expende
festival suave con gases jets y creo
firmemente que ahora es el momento de un
tope del precio del gas ruso a europa
session pipeline gas nag ocupa raúl y la
de respuesta del kremlin no se hizo
esperar dijo que si eso pasara un tope a
los precios de su petróleo y su gas
dejaría de venderles estos recursos
energéticos porque ese límite de precios
desestabilizaría al mercado mundial del
petróleo del gas recordemos que antes de
la guerra rusia era el principal
proveedor de gas de europa y ha venido
cortando esos flujos como represalia por
las acciones occidentales en su cuenta
porque surge esta discusión en el bloque
danny porque europa por supuesto teme
por una crisis energética claro que sí
hay algunos países que dan partes de
tranquilidad cada nación ha adoptado sus
propias estrategias para bajar el
consumo pues nosotros contamos con el
analista niño niño rodríguez sobre cómo
se está preparando europa y si hay
riesgos de un racionamiento severo
estamos trayendo
de noruega de
australia de capaz por supuesto de eeuu
que ahora mismo es el principal
proveedor de gas licuado españa y
tenemos todavía las vías abiertas de lo
que se supone que es la línea de nigeria
y argelia
pasará por cataluña para llegar hasta
europa pero que son proyectos a largo
plazo ahora mismo lo único que tenemos
ahora son barcos que van a traer el gas
a europa
y no hay barcos suficientes como para
cubrir toda la demanda que se necesita
qué es lo que va a suceder pues vamos a
ver el cortes de suministros bastante
graves cortes de suministros
empezando como estoy comentando para
propulsar para catalizar hacia un cambio
de consumo energético de mayor calado y
ya llegados a este punto dani es sin
montar importante entonces entender cómo
funciona el mercado energético en europa
pues raúl presté mucha atención porque
voy a tratar de hacerlo lo más claro
posible el precio de la electricidad
está íntimamente ligado al gas porque
porque en el sistema energético de la
unión europea' los parques eólicos las
plantas nucleares de carbón y de gas y
todos los demás generadores hacen
ofertas diarias en el mercado de la
energía y se les va ubicando primero las
más baratas seguidas de las fuentes más
caras como el gas natural pero el precio
lo termina fijando la que vende más caro
porque todos tienen que remunerar se de
la misma manera quiere decir que por lo
general son las plantas de gas las que
suelen fijar el precio pero eso tiene
sus pros y sus contras que se le pague
más a una planta eólica incentiva una
mayor inversión en la generación
renovable que es bastante necesaria para
alcanzar los objetivos de cambio
climático de europa y en cuanto a sus
defectos están pues hay quienes creen
que el sistema es injusto porque la
energía renovable barata se está
vendiendo a los consumidores por el
mismo precio que la basada en
combustibles fósiles que es mucho más
costosa es por ese entonces danny que el
europea busca una intervención del
mercado para el próximo 9 de septiembre
se van a reunir los ministros de energía
del bloque soft para discutir cómo hacer
frente al aumento de los precios y de
paso también analizar qué reformas
pueden hacerse a más largo plazo algunos
miembros del bloque han expuesto sus
propias propuestas como por ejemplo
limitar el precio para las generadoras
que no sean a gas obligar a la reducción
de la demanda entregar apoyo financiero
a los hogares o subsidiar las facturas
es decir que se establezca un límite en
el precio del gas y los estados paguen a
las generadoras esa diferencia con el
precio del mercado pero todas son
bastante polémicas ya veremos qué sucede
es el 9 de septiembre vamos a ver qué
sucede es 1 de septiembre pero antes
hablemos en nuestra cifra el día por
supuesto por supuesto tiene que ver con
los precios de la energía en europa
porque el 38 3% fue el alza interanual
del precio de este precio de la energía
en agosto en la inflación que fue récord
en la unión europea como uno en agosto
comparado con agosto del año pasado
danny gracias por toda la información
económica y por supuesto nos estamos
viendo siempre aquí en directo américa